The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I like this
lecture because the first half
of my career was
entirely devoted
to the electronic structure
of diatomic molecules.
And this is how you make
sense of diatomic molecules.
Now in 5.111, 5.112, one of
the most exciting thing that
attracts people to
become chemistry majors
is the global interpretation
of the periodic table
in terms of some simple ideas
so that those simple ideas
enable you to predict the
important properties of all
of the atoms.
And that's a pretty
exciting thing to feel like,
yes, it all makes some sense.
And then we go on to
other topics in chemistry,
and we forget about the fact
that we think we understand
the periodic table completely.
We don't use that information.
And one thing that I've tried
to do throughout my career
is to take the simple insights
into the periodic table,
and explain
molecular properties.
And now, this is really a
strange thing because we have
computer programs
that can calculate any
of the properties--
any property you want--
of a small molecule.
So why would we ever
care about being
able to predict the properties--
because we can calculate them?
And the answer is we
want to understand.
We want to be able,
without a computer,
to say this is what we expect
for a particular molecule not
just a diatomic molecule.
What are the things
that control the bonding
in molecules in general and
the properties in molecules
in general?
And if you can understand what
happens in diatomic molecules,
there are very few cases
which would leave you
at a loss for what will be the
properties of this new molecule
that you're looking at.
Or how would you
manipulate a molecule
so that you can force it
to go into the states that
will expose the critical
properties that you want?
So it's this sort
of part of a toolkit
that any practicing
physical chemist who's
worried about spectra,
molecular properties,
electronic properties
would have to master.
And this is really
hard because, one, you
have a computer-- you can
generate the answers completely
accurately.
And two, you're
smart MIT students.
And you believe in
the truth rather than
estimating the truth.
But I like to maintain that
if you can estimate the truth
and find out whether your
estimates are wrong or right,
that enables you
to have confidence
to deal with other
properties, other problems.
And so what I want
to do today is
to give a sense of how
you begin to understand
the electronic structure
of simple molecules.
And I want to tell
you that a lot
of the second-order or
complicated patches you put
on this simple
picture are things
that you develop and criticize
throughout your career.
You say, yeah, well, this
works, but that doesn't.
And why doesn't it work?
And that's what we do
as physical chemists.
We look for when the
simple picture breaks.
And we have our own private
simple pictures which
we're constantly trying to make
better than anybody else's.
OK, so we have the
periodic table.
We know the properties of atoms.
We know, especially, how
the ionization energy
is supposed to behave.
We know how the low-lying
electronic states
are supposed to be ordered.
Excuse me.
We know about orbital sizes.
Everything is related to this
idea of atomic-orbital energies
and shielding.
And it's all related
to the hydrogen atom.
What we got from
the hydrogen atom
was a framework
for understanding
electronic properties of atoms.
And what we know about
electronic properties of atoms
should be important
in explaining
electronic properties
of molecules.
So I want you to be
able to make toy models,
to draw pictures which
are crude, but guiding,
in your insights.
And it's all based
on what we saw.
And you soon are going to have
two lectures from Troy Van
Voorhis, which will lead you to
use some of the simple computer
programs that enable you to
calculate electronic property
of anything.
OK, so we want to extend what
we had for H2+ to be able
to understand H 2 AH,
A 2, and AB molecules.
And each of these steps
involve extensions
of relatively simple ideas.
And so let's begin.
OK, I told you that I believe
the simplest explanation
for bonding is when we have two
atomic orbitals that overlap
in the region where
this overlap region can
be attracted to both nuclei.
Constructive interference
causes the density
in this special region--
the amplitude to be twice
as large, the density
to be four times as large.
And that's a large,
energetic effect.
And the amount of
overlap is crucial.
You can have two little if
the atoms are too far apart--
no bond.
You could have too much if the
atoms are too close together.
OK, so we need to now look
at cartoons of orbitals
and learn about the
names for these orbitals.
So the simplest
orbital is gerade--
sigma gerade NS orbital.
OK, so "sigma" means
there are no nodal planes
containing the
internuclear axis.
"Gerade" means that in the
body frame, it's even symmetry.
So we have ns A plus ns B.
And that looks like this.
We can have an
antibonding orbital.
Again, we put the predominant
atomic-orbital character
in parentheses.
And for heteronuclear
molecules, we also
put which atom is more
important to that orbital.
And this will be
just ns A minus ns.
And that will look like this.
And there is no overlap here.
In fact, there is
negative overlap.
And that's an
antibonding orbital.
And you can say, if
there's no overlap, well,
then the actual
picture will sort of
look like this, where the
region in the binding region
is actually depleted,
and there's less there.
And that's part of
why it's antibonding.
OK.
Now we can also make
sigma g np orbitals.
And np z-- "z" is the
internuclear axis--
A minus and np z, B--
well, that gives us something
that looks like this--
plus, plus, minus, minus.
And the minus sign is
needed to turn this around.
But this is overall
gerade symmetry.
And so everything is fine.
And then we can have
sigma u star np.
And that would just
be the plus sign here.
And that would be an
antibonding orbital.
Now I put a star
on these orbitals
because when we don't
have atomic symmetry, when
we don't have g and
u symmetry, we still
use the star to
imply antibonding.
But in diatomic molecules,
this is redundant.
You should be able,
just by looking
at the orbital character or
looking at a picture, to say,
yes, it's a bonding orbital,
and it's either g or u.
Then we have pi u np.
And that would be--
well, let's do it
the opposite order.
So we'd like to have
something that's bonding.
So we have to have
the phases right.
And that's ungerade
because when you reflect
through the center of the
origin of coordinates,
we go from plus to minus.
So that's ungerade.
But that's bonding.
And that's a little
trick because you
start this think, from sigma,
that ungerade is antibonding.
And finally, we have
the pi g star np.
And that would be plus,
minus, minus, plus.
And that's gerade.
OK, there are a couple other
things that we know just
from these pictures.
And that is the p-sigma orbital
is much more directional
than the s-sigma orbital.
That's all you get
in sigma for s.
And so the bonding interaction
between p-sigma orbitals
turns on at longer
range than for s.
So there's qualitative
differences.
And sometimes, you
have a bond distance
determined by favorable overlap
between one pair of orbitals.
And it makes things not so
good for other orbitals.
So usually, you
have a ground state.
You figure out what the
ground state of molecule is.
And that tells you something
about what the internuclear
distance is.
And then you might grow to
excited states of the molecule
or excited configurations.
And these excited
configurations--
well, if you're going to
learn about a molecule,
you've got to do spectroscopy.
So if you go from the ground
state to an excited state,
and the internuclear
distance of the ground state
is wrong for the excited
state, well, then, you're
going to have a big
change in geometry.
You'll have Frank-Condon
factors, which--
I haven't talked about
Frank-Condon factors--
I will-- that say,
OK, the transition
is going to have a lot
of vibrational structure.
And it'll tell you all sorts
of good stuff about that.
But the important
thing is when you
start looking at a
molecule, you want
to know what the
ground state looks like
and what transitions
from the ground state
ought to look like when
you're ready to know how
to use the simple structural
information you're getting
from these orbitals because
there's no point doing
an experiment if you don't
have an idea about what
the experiment will yield.
That's what most people do
when they do an experiment.
They did the
experiment because they
thought it would
yield something,
and they wanted to be
surprised because they'd
like to show that
maybe it didn't
do what they were expecting.
OK, so we have pictures.
And we have notation.
And this notation
is what is used
by professional spectroscopies,
So we care about directionality.
And we care about
size of orbitals.
And this is definitely
something that you're
empowered from 5.111, 5.112.
I'll talk more about that too.
How about right now?
OK, in thermodynamics,
when we're
concerned about the enthalpy
of formation of a molecule,
we have to set a 0 of enthalpy.
And we set it as separated
atoms in their most-stable state
and energy, or
enthalpy, is something
where there is no natural 0.
We wanted a 0 which
is convenient for all
of our calculations
and insights.
And so what we do is we
say, OK, every particle
that we're going
to be looking at--
we're going to make a
molecule out of two atoms,
like A and B and AB star.
So we have the energy of A
plus electron B plus electron,
or AB plus electron.
That's a common 0 of energy.
So we talk about
orbital energies
relative to this common 0.
Now in almost every textbook,
the orbital diagrams
are given to you.
There's no discussion of,
what's the 0 of energy?
If you're going
to know anything,
you really want to be able
to calculate or to say
all of the actors in this game
are acting in a way related
to how far below this
ionization energy
they are because that
determines their size.
And the size
determines the overlap.
And bonding is
related to overlap.
OK, so we'll play that game.
So for H 2+, it was very simple.
We just had the 1s
at r equals infinity,
and over here, the 1s
orbital at r equals infinity.
And then we solved the
minimal-basis variational
problem.
And we discovered that we had
something like this, where this
is the antibonding orbital.
This is the binding orbital.
The antibonding orbital
is more antibonding
than the bonding
orbital is bonding.
And, of course, this
energy difference
depends on
internuclear distance,
also not often talked about.
And so we have the starting
point at r equals infinity
for the separated atoms.
Now as we bring
these atoms together,
before there's any
bonding at all,
say, we have 1s on A.
We make the internuclear
distance smaller and smaller.
And the bare nucleus
of the other atom
starts to penetrate into the--
so as you move the
positively charged nucleus
towards the static
charge on the other atom,
that's a favorable interaction.
But there's a repulsion
between the two nuclei.
And when the bare
nucleus of one atom
penetrates inside the charge
distribution of the other,
it sees less attraction
and more repulsion.
And so this is why you
get a potential curve that
looks like this.
The repulsion occurs at
too-short internuclear
distance.
And from the
variational calculation,
you can determine the value
of equilibrium internuclear
distance.
And so a lot of
these diagrams are
calculated at this particular
internuclear distance.
It's especially important
because the repulsive states
don't have a minimum.
And so there is no particular
internuclear distance
that you care about so that
if you want a simple picture,
everything is calculated at
that particular internuclear
distance.
OK, so sometimes, you want to
have a little bit more insight
in this picture.
And instead of drawing
the starting point
at infinite separation,
you could say, well,
let's schematically suggest
what happens as you--
so at shorter
internuclear distance,
the separated atom energy
increases a little bit.
And that could be useful.
But it complicates things,
so I won't do that.
But often, we do
like to know what
happens as we bring particles
together as opposed to starting
at infinity and coming
into the end point, which
is the bond at the equilibrium
internuclear distance.
So you can put that
insight in if you wish.
So we know that this bonding
interaction is smaller
than the antibonding
interaction.
OK, we can now go
from H 2+ to H 2.
And the first thing we know is
when we go from H 2+ to H 2,
we can put an electron into the
same orbital but with opposite
spin.
And as a result, we
don't have to worry
about mysterious things,
like overlap repulsion
or poly-repulsion because
we're putting electrons
into different spin orbitals.
And that's all you have to do.
If you try to put two electrons
into the same spin orbital,
that's really bad.
And once we get beyond
hydrogen-- hydrogen
has this neat situation
that there is no core.
It's just the nuclei.
But for anything other
than hydrides or hydrogen,
we have an inner
core, which is filled
with electrons of both spins.
So anytime you have
an orbital that
gets too close to
the other atom,
there is going to be this
mysterious overlap repulsion.
And that makes the inner
wall of most potentials other
than hydrogen
extremely vertical.
OK, so let me just--
oh, I know what I wanted to
say, but i will get to that
When we go from H 2+ to H 2, we
discover that the equilibrium
in our internuclear distance
decreases by approximately 30%.
The vibrational frequency
increases by 90%.
The dissociation energy
increases by about 70%.
These are big effects.
They're not a factor of 2.
Naively, if one
electron gives a bond
or gives some sort of
a bonding interaction,
two should give twice that much.
But this is pretty close
to twice that much.
Even though that's only
30%, it's a big effect.
And it's because
we're allowed to put
an electron into an
orbital which is bonding.
And there is no
magic-overlap repulsion.
There is just the
interelectronic-energy
repulsion.
So our picture is--
we're chemists.
We believe in bonds.
The most important
thing is bonds.
And in almost every
situation, you
want to conserve
the number of bonds
or know how much you
have to pay for changing
the number of bonds.
That's the course.
But we're more sophisticated.
Now in our picture for H 2+,
we had an effective Hamiltonian
or a variational calculation.
I like to talk about
effective Hamiltonians.
But the crucial actors
in the H 2+ problem,
or the overlap is a function
R, the interaction energy
as a function of R, and the
orbital energy is a function
of R. And these are the
actors in almost all further
calculations.
You're going to want to
either know these things
or be able to estimate
their sizes so you
know the consequences.
And we know much of the
consequences from H 2+.
We know that as R decreases,
the overlap increases,
the increases, and
the interaction
energy between the
two atoms increases.
So these are the factors that
we put into a calculation.
We know that there
is a bonding region.
And typically, we can say that
the bonding region for H 2+
and for any molecule is
going to be roughly between
the atomic-orbital radius and
twice the atomic-orbital radius
because we've got two atoms.
And so they want to see
it at twice that radius.
And then as we get
closer, we get bonding.
And as we get too close,
we get antibonding.
And so this is a
critical region.
Now we're ready to take
the next few steps.
So we want to do H
2+ to H 2 to A 2.
And so the questions we
ask is, how many electrons?
That's easy.
Feed the energy electrons
into lowest MOs.
Well, in order to
do that, you need
to know the energy
order of the MOs.
We get a configuration,
which is just
a list of the number
of electrons in each
of the molecular orbitals.
And these configurations
have particular states.
And for a diatonic molecule,
we know the projection
of the electron
orbital-angular momentum
on the other nuclear axis,
lambda, we know the spin.
And sometimes, we know
about this thing, omega,
which is the
projection of the spin,
as well as the projection of
the orbital-angular momentum.
And so we have a notation
for electronic states, which
will be lambda 2s plus 1 omega.
And so say we have a triplet.
Well, this triplet
will be 2s plus 1 is 3.
And this is pi, say.
So the correct way to
say that is not "3 pi."
but "triplet pi."
And we normally don't talk about
that in any special notation.
So the splittings of the
configurations for H2--
we have the ground state.
And that's sigma g 1s squared,
and the lowest excited
state, triplet sigma u plus--
and that's sigma
g 1s sigma u us.
So we have these pictures.
And this is bound.
This has got a binding orbital
and an antibonding orbital.
This is a sigma u 1s.
Sorry-- so antibonding.
So this is repulsive.
Or usually, it's repulsive
at all internucleuses.
Then there are higher-energy
orbitals that come from 2p--
2p pi and 2p sigma.
And they give rise
to many, many states.
But we know, for hydrogen,
when we go from 1s to 2p,
we're at very,
very high energy--
3/4 of a Rydberg.
And that's an energy that's
larger than any chemical bond
we know.
So the excited states
of H 2 are going
to be a little bit weird because
of this tremendous excitation
energy.
And because the excitation
energy is so high,
we're probably not
prepared to understand
what's going on up there.
And in fact, terrible things
happen up at high energy.
We get there are some curves
that are double minima.
There are all sorts of things.
And they have to do with--
you could have H+
H- ion-pair states.
You can have H 2+
plus electron--
those are Rydberg states as well
as the normal valence states.
So normally, we don't
want to worry about that.
And there are two
places we don't
want to go without preparation.
One is to very high
excitation energy.
And the other is to very
large internuclear distance
because things can happen.
The weirdnesses are
much more important
when there is no core.
So since everything
is dependent on R,
we need to know how to estimate
the internuclear distance.
And we know, for
an atomic orbital,
the ionization energy
is hc times the Rydberg
constant over n squared.
And we know that the
average r for an orbital
is a0 times n squared
over the charge.
And so if we want to relate
the size of an orbital
to something that
we can measure,
well, we can simply put in this
equation for n squared here.
And we get that the
average size of an orbital
will be a 0, which is the Bohr
radius of the hydrogen atom--
about half an angstrom--
times hcR.
The Rydberg is
110,000 wave numbers--
and over z--
I'm sorry-- over I nl.
So this ionization
energy is measured.
And so if you know the
ionization energy, you know r.
If you are talking about a
molecular-orbital diagram,
you have r and
ionization energy on it.
And so you can see how
it would make everything
relate to each other.
OK, let's do an example.
Let's look at the NH molecule.
This is not a stable
molecule, but it's
a molecule that is important
in some chemical reactions.
It's easy to make an H by
having, say, nitrogen--
N2-- and hydrogen and
doing a discharge.
And so in order to be
able to understand H,
you start out with all
of the orbital energies.
So let's make a little table.
We have H 1s.
And we have its
ionization energy.
And its 13.6 electoral volts.
We have H 2s and 2p for
hydrogen. They're degenerate.
And that's 3.4 electron volts--
for nitrogen, 1s.
This is an obscenely
large energy.
And so it's greater
than 100 electron volts.
We have N 2s, which
is 18 electron volts.
We have N 2p, which
is 12 electron volts.
And we're going to have, at the
end, the ground state of NH,
which turns out to be a
triplet sigma, g minus state.
And that's at 13.6 ev.
So one of the things you want to
do is ask, OK, all my actors--
where are they below
the ionization energy?
And the next thing you do is you
arrange things in energy order.
And so the lowest one is this.
And it's out of the
picture altogether.
The next lowest one is this.
And then we have two.
And let's just say this is
3 to 4, and this is 4 to 3.
They're roughly degenerate.
That's what we're
looking for because when
the orbitals are
degenerate, they
have about the same energy.
And we know from
perturbation theory,
if you want to have a mixture
of two different things,
you want the energy to
not measure to be small.
So all the actors--
the simple stuff--
we know what their energies are.
We know that if we have two
things that have the same,
or nearly the same, energy,
they're going to be mixed.
And so now, with this sort
of an annotated table--
the last one is this guy--
we can write down the
low-lying configurations.
And we can say something
about the nature
of the molecular-orbital
diagram.
[INAUDIBLE]
But I stress the
most important thing
is something that's easily
measured for atoms because what
we want to do is
build on what we think
we know for the periodic table
to have some sort of insight
into molecular-periodic
table, although it's
a multidimensional
periodic table.
I know that's probably
a stupid thing to say.
OK, so here's the molecular
orbital diagram for NH.
So over on this
side, we have H+.
Over this side, we have N+.
And we put the orbitals on--
OK, so here is minus 3.4,
which is the hydrogen 2s or 2p.
And down here, we
have the hydrogen 1s.
And that's at minus 13.6.
And over here, we
have the nitrogen 2p.
And that's at minus 12.
So what do we do?
And then down much farther
below way down here,
we have the nitrogen 1s.
The nitrogen 2s.
OK, how many
electrons do we have?
Well, before I do that--
so how many electrons
are on nitrogen?
I mean, if you don't
do that, you don't
know the periodic table at all.
How many?
Did everybody see that?
Well, then I can't ask you.
Yes, it's seven electrons and
plus 1 for the hydrogen, right?
So we're dealing
with eight electrons.
And so we're going to put
eight electrons into orbitals.
And now on this
diagram, basically, I
have two orbitals that are
roughly at the same energy.
And so we know that all the
action is going to be that.
And so we can draw something
like this and something
like that.
And now, we use our
perturbation ideas.
And this guy is
higher in energy.
And so it's closer to
this other orbital.
So this one is
dominantly nitrogen,
and this one is dominantly
hydrogen. Make this dotted.
OK, so we have two orbitals.
This one is polarized
towards nitrogen.
And this one is polarized
towards hydrogen.
And then there is
another orbital here.
This is 2p pi.
Well, what about 2p pi?
There is no pi orbital here.
The lowest pi orbital
is way up here.
So this guy is nonbinding.
So we have a bonding orbital,
a nonbonding orbital,
and an antibonding orbital.
And then up here,
we have something
that's so high energy, we
might call it a Rydberg
orbital or just something else.
OK, so now we start
putting electrons
into orbitals in
orbital-order energy.
So we have sigma
nitrogen 1s squared.
That's the lowest one.
That's way down here.
I erased it.
It's at minus 100
electron volts.
And then we have nitrogen 2s.
That's pretty far down too.
And so these two--
we don't have any doubt.
The electrons go into
these sigma orbitals.
And there's nobody
nearby, and so these are
localized on the nitrogen atom.
We've got four more
electrons to deal with.
We have sigma NH sigma NH.
Well, we'll call this sigma.
We got two electrons there.
And then we have--
so we got two electrons, two
electrons in core orbitals.
We have a bond.
Then we have a nonbond.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How far
apart in energy
do the orbitals have
to be such that you
consider them non-attracted?
PROFESSOR: It's
really up to you.
I mean, at the lowest--
it's a question
of how much detail
you want to be honest about.
There's always interaction.
But the important thing
is if the orbital energy
is really low or stable, the
orbitals are really compact.
And so at equally
internuclear distance,
which is determined
by a bonding orbital,
they're just out of play.
So it's not 0.
But you really care
about big effects--
things that are worth,
roughly, the energy
of a tenth of a bond.
As you get more and
more better at this,
you could say, well, we'll
worry about bonding effects that
are worth less than a tenth
of a bond or a typical bond.
But you want to organize things
in the order of how important
they are, how careful
you have to be,
how many subtle effects you
have to take into account.
And so to avoid craziness,
you want to say,
I'm not going to worry about
this because it's too small,
or because their energy
difference is too large.
And it's very important
to be able to shed
unnecessary factors until
you're ready to deal with them.
Or maybe you never will.
OK, so that was a
really great question.
All right, so we
have the list of--
where did I put it?
Oh, here it is.
OK, so these are
three filled orbitals.
They give rise to
a singlet sigma.
But we have two electrons
in a pi orbital.
And if you care
about this stuff,
you'll learn how to figure
out what two electrons in a pi
orbital will give you.
And they give you
triplet sigma minus g--
I'm sorry-- no g because it's
a heteronuclear-- triplet
sigma minus singlet delta
and singlet sigma plus.
And this is actually much easier
than for inorganic chemistry
or for just figuring out
the LS states of an atom
because basically, we
have sigma, pi, delta.
And you can figure
out, well, pi squared
is going to give you this.
Pi cubed is going to give
you this again, except this--
it's going to give
you this again.
So you there's a
finite number of things
that you don't have to
work out the energy levels
by an elaborate procedure.
And so you can sort
of memorize them
because there's very
few that you actually
are going to deal with.
OK, so now Hund's rules
apply to molecules.
So what's the
ground state of NH?
Triplet sigma minus.
So that's nice because you're
going to be doing spectroscopy,
and you're going to be
starting with a molecule
in a triplet state and
you've got a pi bond.
And so you know a typical
internuclear distance for a pi
bond, or you can figure it out.
And we're only going to
be seeing triplet states,
and we're only
going to be seeing
triplet-sigma-minus states
or triplet-pi states because
of the selection rules.
Now I'm telling you this.
You could learn that.
These are extra things.
You've got to know the
most-important stuff.
So we have an
intentionally naive
primitive-molecular
orbital diagram.
OK, now-- my chance
to say terrible things
about textbooks.
Every one of you has seen
the molecular-orbital diagram
for this mystical A2 molecule.
Everybody's seen it.
And it's presented either
dishonestly or semihonestly
with an asterisk.
So let's just understand this.
Again we have the
ionization energy.
We have A+ and A+.
And we plot the energies.
And naively, we
say, OK, here's 2s--
same energy 2s.
And here is 2p--
2p-- for atoms other than
hydrogen, 2p is above 2s.
And so we know, well,
we can draw some kind
of a diagram like this.
So these are the sigma
star 2s and sigma 2s.
No problem.
And then we draw something
like this for the p orbitals.
And we have something like this.
That makes sense.
Now, the lowest-energy
orbital has
to be the more
directional p orbital.
So this is going to be
the p-sigma orbital.
And so we'll have a sigma
2p, a pi 2p, a pi star 2p,
and a sigma star 2p.
That's what you get
using common sense.
And it's wrong.
And most of the
textbooks say, well,
if we have to correct
this-- it turns out
that the energy order
of these two orbitals
is frequently reversed.
And most textbooks
don't tell you why.
They just say, well, this
is what you would expect.
And the canonical
molecular-orbital diagram
for homonuclear diatomics
has the pi below sigma
except for oxygen and fluorine.
Well, that's not something
that builds confidence.
And that's something you
learned in 5.111, 5.112.
The energy gap between 2s
and 2p depends on shielding.
And so as you start out with
lithium, 2s and 2p are--
lithium is more like
hydrogen. So 2s and 2p
are nearly degenerate.
When you get to fluorine, the
energy gap between 2s and 2p
is enormous because
2s shields 2p.
And as a result, the--
well, the shielding arguments
explain this energy gap.
And it gets large
because 2s is unshielded,
and it really gets very stable,
whereas 2p is increasingly
affected by the shielding by
s, and as a charge, increases
the orbital energy.
OK, I thought I had a
better explanation for it.
But I do have one.
It's just not handy.
And so what happens?
Well, what happens, as
you go from lithium, where
this and this are
close together,
you have interaction between
orbitals of the same symmetry.
Now the Hamiltonian
is totally symmetric.
Oh, my goodness.
So because the Hamiltonian
is totally symmetric,
you can have interactions
between orbitals
of the same symmetry.
And as a result, this
guy gets pushed up.
And this guy gets pushed up.
And this guy gets pushed down.
But these are so far out of
the picture you don't care.
So it's really just the
relative energies of these two.
And it's all due to the
relative energies of 2s and 2p.
And then you get the correct
energy-level diagram.
And you say, well, maybe as we
went across the periodic table,
there will be a switch.
And there is a switch.
And since I've lived most
of my early life in CO
and N 2 and O 2.
I've encountered that.
And I thought about it a lot.
OK so that's pretty
much all I'm going
to say about the
molecular-orbital diagram.
I think next lecture
is on Huckel theory.
OK.